right now to a rare public dispute
between NATO and Ukraine the U.S and
NATO say the missile that killed two
people in Poland was actually fired by
Ukraine which was defending itself
against the Russian barrage but
Ukraine's government says the missile is
Russian we've got correspondence in both
Poland and Ukraine we begin with Charlie
dagada in Poland Charlie good morning
good morning here's the scene this
morning in the village where that
missile landed police have cordoned off
the area it struck a grain facility
killing two men just a few hundred yards
away from this school which remains shut
today there is a military presence here
soldiers on the streets residents still
in a State of Shock we're told U.S
investigators have been working with
Polish teams on the ground polish
officials reiterating there is no
evidence that the missile was launched
by the Russian side that tallies with
the U.S and NATO however Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski has broken
ranks saying this is not our missile and
not our missile strike President Biden
reacted to those remarks saying that's
not the evidence
Ukrainian officials have been demanding
access to the site the president's
office here said that's likely to happen
it's just a question of when now for
what's happening inside Ukraine here's
Chris live say
Charlotte Ukraine awoke to get another
barrage of Russian missiles several
reportedly shot down right here in
dinipro but not this one
that blast wounded 14 people including a
15 year old girl undergoing surgery now
president zielinski was initially
adamant that it was not a Ukrainian
missile that struck Poland but a Russian
one however this morning the spokesman
for Ukraine's Air Force was less certain
he told CBS news that it didn't matter
whose rocket it was ukraines or Russia's
since it was during a Russian airstrike
that triggered Ukraine's defenses and he
added Ukraine's Air Force is still
Gathering evidence and now president
zielinski is stressing the same points
saying we need our Specialists to join
the work of the international
investigation and for us to get access
to all the data from the site of the
explosion available to our partners Nate
Chris and Charlie on the scene thank you